hi I'm SEMA hello I'm Philippa hello I'm
Luke and we are the cast of One True
Love there are settings
in the film one true loves my character
Jesse spends time on a desert island so
now we're going to play would you rather
desert island Edition with what we'd
rather have on the desert island with us
if we were unlucky enough to be stranded
on one let's do it
would you rather a dog companion or a
human companion I love my dogs
um I'm gonna go for human companion
because I think opposable thumbs are
very important on a desert island sort
of situation yeah I think a human
companion your chances for survival are
higher much higher yeah yeah I go human
and also as well the Heartbreak you know
I think there's things that can go wrong
with the dog and that would
would you rather
Vegemite or peanut butter on a desert
island Vegemite peanut butter baby I'm
gonna say peanut butter I had the chance
the wonderful privilege of trying
Vegemite while I was shooting
um in Australia uh and and I got it I'm
gonna peanut butter would you rather
romance novels or sci-fi novels I don't
think there's anything romantic about
being stuck by yourself on a desert
island so I'd go sci-fi maybe it'll
teach me something maybe I'll maybe I'll
come up with like a maybe your
imagination my imagination will come up
with a way to get out yes I'd go sci-fi
for the Escape you know yeah you're just
there the days grow long maybe you want
something like to take you out of that
place maybe romance novels just to
remind you of what life and love is to
keep you connected to humanity which is
something you might lose on a desert
island this one's specifically for me a
year's supply of wine or a year's supply
Diet Coke
um clearly the writer of this question
knows that I do not drink and um if
you're stuck on a desert island what am
I gonna have warm Diet Cokes give me the
wine give me the wine I'll learn to like
it one one ah great juice every day of
the way
twice on Sundays here we go would you
rather oh this is useful a fishing pole
fish with it
that's pretty much it that's pretty much
it a tent you could use the tent as
shelter also use the tent to make
potentially a sail
for a raft if you want to get off and
you could make a fishing pole out
absolutely I think you could fashion a
spear you could fashion a fishing rod
yeah think about that just that full
waterproof like you don't have to worry
you sleep dry to get out of the sun oh
yeah tent yeah okay would you rather
a radio that plays The Hot 100 or a
record collection of classics classics
for me no but can you use the radio to
like yeah no because it's another
two-way radio it's a have you ever tried
to talk into your car radio then I would
go with the classics
would you rather Unlimited Supply of
toilet paper
or
bug spray bug spray what can you do with
unlimited toilet paper you could um I
just feel like imagine you're like I
need to blow my nose or like I have
something in my eye I could start a fire
with the toilet I think about the fire
with the bug spray I think with an
unlimited amount of toilet paper
infinite you could just build a boat
an infinite amount you said you said
unlimited right I'm I'm just gonna take
the question you could go a bridge you
can build a toilet paper boat you could
absorb the entire room you could absorb
the entire ocean I don't know what to
say and then just be on your Merry way
[Music]
would you rather a portable fan for the
hot days or an extra blanket for the
cold days
extra blanket for the cold days hot days
find yourself a little bit of shade go
for a swim yeah one of the only
advantages of being on a desert island
is surrounded by water blankets
last one
would you rather a year's supply of
sweet treats or a year's supply of salty
snacks a year's supply so you don't know
how long you're going to be on the
island for and it's only it's not the
it's not unlimited like the toilet paper
situation
so it's a year so it's a year's supply
yeah I think it's good it would be good
moral boost to have like a Year's worth
of sweets over there you're just looking
at you like oh if when it went at all
when I get really sad I've got some of
the treats to go this is salty because I
just like salty better I do like salty
better I mean guys thank God that we're
not on a real does violin right for me
thank God I'm not on one anymore
make sure you catch all three of us on
one true loves
[Music]